Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I have fallen in love with American names, the sharp names that never get fat, the snakeskin titles of mining claims, the plumed war bonnet of medicine hat, Tucson and Deadwood and lost mule flat. I shall not rest quiet in Montparnasse, I shall not lie easy at Winchelsea. You may bury my body in Sussex grass. You may bury my tongue at Champmedie. I shall not be there. I shall rise and pass. Bury my heart at Wounded Knee. So that was a poem written in 1927 by Stephen Vincent, who was from an army family, Dominic.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的加更节目、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我爱上了美国的地名，那些从不臃肿的干练名称，那些如蛇皮般斑驳的矿区名，那些如药帽般羽饰的战争头饰，图森（Tucson）、死木镇（Deadwood）和迷骡平原（Lost Mule Flat）。我不会在蒙帕纳斯（Montparnasse）安息，我不会在温切尔西（Winchelsea）长眠。你可以把我的尸体埋在萨塞克斯（Sussex）的草丛中，你可以把我的舌头埋在尚梅迪（Champmedie）。我不会在那里。我会起身离去。把我的心埋在伤膝河（Wounded Knee）。所以，这是一首由斯蒂芬·文森特（Stephen Vincent）在1927年创作的诗，他来自一个军人家庭，多米尼克。
It was. I assume had been to France and England, maybe with the Great War. Help me out here. I'm reading your notes. I don't know. It's this great celebration of American place names, isn't it? And saying, you know, you can shove your European place names. I don't know if he'd been to Montparnasse and Sussex.
确实。我猜他可能在“一战”期间去过法国和英国。帮我回忆一下，我正在读你的笔记，我也不太清楚。这首诗是对美国地名的一场盛大赞美，不是吗？它仿佛在说，你们那些欧洲地名可以靠边站了。我不知道他是否真的去过蒙帕纳斯和萨塞克斯。
Or Winchelsea. I mean, it's not an obvious no anyway listen this is by the by of course the reason why we have read that is that bury my heart at wounded knee yeah has given its name to perhaps the best known work of history on native americans and it foregrounds its ending it does because the massacre at wounded knee is generally seen as providing the terrible coda to the tragic history of Native Americans over the course of their encounter with European settlers. Yeah. And this is going to be the climax of our story too. It is indeed. It's extraordinary that he chose to end that way because, you know, today we think of Wounded Knee and we think of Dee Brown's book, which was published in 1970,
或者温切尔西。我的意思是，这并不是显而易见的，总之，我们读这首诗的原因是，“把我的心埋在伤膝河”这个标题，赋予了那本关于美洲原住民最著名的历史著作以书名，它突出了结局，确实如此，因为伤膝河大屠杀通常被视为美洲原住民在与欧洲定居者接触过程中，那段悲剧历史的惨痛尾声。是的。这也将是我们故事的高潮。确实如此。他选择以这种方式结束真是非同寻常，因为今天我们提到伤膝河，就会想到迪·布朗（Dee Brown）1970年出版的那本书，
and then the occupation of the site a few years later by Native American activists protesting against their kind of, what they saw as their mistreatment by the federal government. But I'm guessing maybe in 1927, Wounded Knee didn't have that resonance. It just seemed like a very American name. And so he ends his poem with those words. Well, it's right in the middle, isn't it? It's in the middle of America.
以及几年后美洲原住民活动家对该遗址的占领，他们以此抗议联邦政府对他们的虐待。但我猜在1927年，伤膝河可能还没有那种共鸣。它当时只是听起来像一个非常美国化的名字。所以他用这些词结束了他的诗。嗯，它就在中间，不是吗？它就在美国的中心地带。
Yeah. So we'll come to the Wounded Knee Massacre, which, as you say, is an extraordinary story, and we'll explore it in some detail, because it's all about this kind of religious movement called the Ghost Dance, which is itself absolutely fascinating. Dominic, you know I love a religious movement. absolutely fascinating dominic you know i love a religious movement i know but listeners who are still with us after 63 episodes of this mighty series will know that of course custer was killed at uh the battle of the little big horn in 1876 but afterwards the lakota dispersed and were basically rounded up and picked off by uh crook and miles and these other very ruthless American, very effective US Army officers. Crazy Horse was killed.
是的。所以我们将谈到伤膝河大屠杀，正如你所说，这是一个非同寻常的故事，我们将详细探讨它，因为它与一种被称为“鬼舞”（Ghost Dance）的宗教运动有关，这本身就绝对令人着迷。多米尼克，你知道我喜欢宗教运动。绝对令人着迷，多米尼克，你知道我喜欢宗教运动。我知道，但那些在这一宏大系列节目播出63集后依然陪伴我们的听众会知道，卡斯特（Custer）当然是在1876年的小大角战役（Battle of the Little Bighorn）中阵亡的，但此后拉科塔人（Lakota）四散奔逃，基本上被克鲁克（Crook）、迈尔斯（Miles）以及其他那些非常冷酷、非常高效的美国陆军军官围捕并逐一消灭。疯马（Crazy Horse）被杀了。
We described that last time. Terrible, kind of pitiable end that he came to. Lying on the ground, as you described, Tom. Not on a cot, because he was still kind of at one with the earth. Sitting Bull had fled to Canada, then come back, being incarcerated in Fort Randall. And finally, in May 1883, he had arrived at the Standing Rock Reservation. And he hopes, I think at that point, that that's the end of it. You know, he can get on with his life and he will be left alone, which is what Crazy Horse wanted.
我们上次描述过。他死得非常凄惨。汤姆，正如你所描述的那样，他躺在地上。不是躺在行军床上，因为他依然与大地融为一体。坐牛（Sitting Bull）逃到了加拿大，后来又回来，被关押在兰德尔堡（Fort Randall）。最终，在1883年5月，他抵达了立岩保留地（Standing Rock Reservation）。我想在那时，他希望这就是终点。你知道，他可以继续他的生活，不再被打扰，这正是疯马所想要的。
But what he realizes when he arrives in Standing Rock is that everything has changed while he's been away. Those processes of change have now worked themselves out. And what was once Indian country has been completely transformed. So the railroad, after the US economy recovered, after the panic of 1873, there is an explosion of railroad building, 2,000 miles of track across South Dakota alone between 1878 and 1887, bringing in the settlers and food and supplies and all that stuff. And also, of course, Dominic, buffalo hunters. And buffalo hunters, yeah.
但他到达立岩时意识到，在他离开的这段时间里，一切都变了。那些变革的过程已经彻底完成。曾经的印第安领地已经面目全非。随着美国经济在1873年恐慌后复苏，铁路建设出现了爆发式增长，仅在1878年至1887年间，南达科他州就铺设了2000英里的轨道，带来了定居者、食物、补给品等等。当然，多米尼克，还有水牛猎人。还有水牛猎人，是的。
And finishing off the process of destruction that Sitting Bull was already all too well aware of in the aftermath of the Little Bighorn because they can't find any game then. That's right. And this is the theme of kind of the terrible ending of Blood Meridian, Cormac McCarthy's great novel. So he has this awful description of what the planes look like, and it's too long to read, but it's just a little excerpt. The flint hides by the hundred ton and the meat rotting on the ground and the air whining with flies and the buzzards and ravens and the night a horror of snarling and feeding with the wolves
他们完成了毁灭的过程，坐牛在小大角战役后对此已经非常清楚，因为那时他们已经找不到任何猎物了。没错。这就是科马克·麦卡锡（Cormac McCarthy）的伟大小说《血色子午线》（Blood Meridian）中那种可怕结局的主题。他有一段关于平原景象的恐怖描写，太长了读不完，但这只是一个小片段：百吨重的燧石兽皮，腐烂在地面上的肉，空气中嗡嗡作响的苍蝇，秃鹫和乌鸦，夜晚则是狼群咆哮和进食的恐怖景象，
half crazed and wallowing in the carrion and then when the carrion is gone nothing but the bones and then when the bones have been shipped off just emptiness yeah that's exactly right so as late as 1876 there was still two million buffalo bison technically in wyoming and montana six years later a rancher was traveling across the plains and he said in all that time i was never out of sight of a dead buffalo and i never was in sight of a live one. There are actually now more cattle, far more cattle that have been brought in. Right. And so this is when the cowboys turn up. So the cowboys are not fighting Indians. No. The cowboys come when the Indians have been cleared off and they're bringing barbed wire, aren't they? And then legislators in Washington in the 1880s start
半疯癫地在腐肉中打滚，当腐肉消失后，只剩下骨头，当骨头被运走后，就只剩下虚无。是的，完全正确。早在1876年，怀俄明州和蒙大拿州还有两百万头水牛（严格来说是美洲野牛）。六年之后，一位牧场主穿越平原时说，在那段时间里，我从未离开过死水牛的视线，也从未见过一头活的水牛。现在实际上有更多的牛，被带进来的牛多得多。没错。这就是牛仔出现的时候。所以牛仔们并不是在与印第安人作战。不。牛仔们是在印第安人被清除后才来的，他们带来了铁丝网，不是吗？然后19世纪80年代华盛顿的立法者开始
parceling up what had been Indian land and handing it out to farmers. And the process of Western civilization kicks in. Yeah. Barbed wire is a really big thing. It's also bad luck, I suppose, for those people who want to preserve the old way of life. In the late 1870s, very early 1880s, you have a wet weather cycle. So a lot of rain, the soil is unusually fertile. The railroad companies are advertising this and they say, wow, this is incredible. You know, this is the promised land of America. You can come here and start a farm and you'll be growing all these amazing things.
将曾经的印第安土地分割开来，分发给农民。西方文明的进程开始了。是的。铁丝网确实是一件大事。我想，对于那些想要保留旧生活方式的人来说，这也是不幸的。在19世纪70年代末到80年代初，有一个多雨的气候周期。所以雨水很多，土壤异常肥沃。铁路公司大肆宣传，他们说，哇，这太不可思议了。你知道，这是美国的应许之地。你可以来这里开垦农场，种植各种神奇的作物。
And so in 20 years or so, six towns in South Dakota become more than 300 towns. There were fewer than 2,000 farms in 1860 or so. Now there are 50,000. There are people flooding in. And that topsoil is not going to stay there for long, is it? No, no, exactly. And actually, they're being sold a lie as well. A lie, because actually, it's not terribly fertile land,
于是大约20年里，南达科他州的6个城镇变成了300多个城镇。1860年左右农场不到2000个。现在有5万个。人们蜂拥而至。而那层表土不会在那里停留太久，对吧？不，不，完全正确。而且实际上，他们也被谎言欺骗了。一个谎言，因为实际上，那里的土地并不是特别肥沃，
and it's not going to prove incredibly productive. So, I mean, it's eerie to cross the Great Plains because it's haunted by the ghosts of the buffalo. It's haunted by the ghosts of the Native American communities that lived there, the peoples that lived there. But it's also haunted by the kind of the relics of that very brief boom period that follows in the wake of the ending of the Indian Wars. Yeah. The disappointed hopes of the people who moved to the Great Plains and ended up joining the populist movement at the end of the 20th century. And then later on, of course, they've got the Great Depression to come. I mean, that would all happen in one lifetime. Anyway, so Sitting Bull arrives at the agency
而且也不会证明具有惊人的生产力。所以，穿越大平原令人毛骨悚然，因为它被水牛的幽灵所困扰。它被曾经居住在那里的美洲原住民社区、那些民族的幽灵所困扰。但它也被印第安战争结束后那段短暂繁荣期的遗迹所困扰。是的。那些搬到大平原并最终在20世纪末加入民粹主义运动的人们，他们的希望破灭了。后来，当然，他们还要面对大萧条。我的意思是，这一切都会在一个人的一生中发生。总之，坐牛到达了代理处，
and what does he find? There are now about 17,000 Lakota left, only 17,000. They are corralled in this tract in what is now South Dakota of about 35,000 miles. One historian describes it as six seas of misery, each swirling around a single agency island. So the different kind of Lakota tribes have been allotted different agencies. So Pine Ridge, the Rosebud, Standing Rock, the Cheyenne River, and so on. And each of those has an agent who looks after it, who gives out rations and so on. And there'll be a sort of a little encampment and whatnot. And there'll be a school and these kinds of things. The historian Peter Cousins, who wrote a really detailed book about the Indian wars, he says what had happened
他发现了什么？现在只剩下大约17000名拉科塔人，只有17000人。他们被圈禁在现在南达科他州约35000英里的地带。一位历史学家将其描述为六片苦难之海，每一片都围绕着一个代理处孤岛旋转。所以不同的拉科塔部落被分配到了不同的代理处。比如松岭（Pine Ridge）、玫瑰花蕾（Rosebud）、立岩（Standing Rock）、夏延河（Cheyenne River）等等。每一个代理处都有一名负责照看的代理人，负责发放口粮等等。那里会有一些小营地之类的东西。会有学校和诸如此类的设施。写过关于印第安战争详细著作的历史学家彼得·考辛斯（Peter Cousins）说，大苏族保留地（Great Sioux Reservation）发生的事情是，
to the Great Sioux Reservation is that it had become a sealed laboratory for social engineering. So we talked before about how there was this sort of Christianizing mission in the 1870s and 1880s. People who saw themselves as reformers and kind-hearted progressives who wanted to lead the Indian, as they would have called the native population, to lead the Indian into as they would have called the native population, to lead the Indian into the new dawn of civilization. Well, the whole thing of taking children and educating them, which has been a topic of immense controversy recently in Canada and Australia, hasn't it? Yes. I mean, it's happening in the Great Plains as well. We talked about in the last episode how Sitting Bull said that he wanted his children to be raised as Americans. It's kind of interesting. The very last war party is actually five boys who break
它已经变成了一个社会工程的密封实验室。所以我们之前谈到过19世纪70年代和80年代那种基督教化的使命。那些自认为是改革者和善良进步派的人，想要引导印第安人——他们对原住民的称呼——引导印第安人进入文明的新曙光。嗯，把孩子们带走并教育他们，这在加拿大和澳大利亚最近引起了巨大的争议，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，这在大平原上也正在发生。我们在上一集谈到坐牛说他希望他的孩子们像美国人一样被抚养长大。这很有趣。最后一支战争小分队实际上是五个从寄宿学校逃出来的男孩，
out of a boarding school. Really? Kind of Indian boys who break out of a boarding school, go on the rampage. Crikey. So what happens is, I mean, the Commissioner of Indian Affairs said, to domesticate wild Indians is a noble work, the crown of glory to any nation we're not going to allow them to drag along in their old superstition laziness and filth we can elevate them in the scale of humanity but also it breaks down the what we would call the tribes totally they want to break down the tribes the ambition is to make them americans individuals stamp out what they call demoralizing and barbarous customs they want to remove the sun dance so no more Sundances. Violent, barbaric, bloody. Why would we want this to continue? And as you said, putting kids into boarding schools. So the first boarding schools were opened in Pennsylvania in 1879. The kids
真的吗？从寄宿学校逃出来的印第安男孩，开始横冲直撞。天哪。所以发生的事情是，印第安事务专员说，驯化野蛮的印第安人是一项崇高的工作，是任何国家的荣耀之冠，我们不会允许他们沉溺于旧有的迷信、懒惰和肮脏之中，我们可以提升他们的人性水平，但这同时也彻底瓦解了我们所说的部落，他们想要瓦解部落。他们的野心是让他们成为美国人，成为个体，铲除他们所谓的堕落和野蛮习俗。他们想要取消太阳舞（Sun Dance），所以不再有太阳舞了。暴力、野蛮、血腥。我们为什么要让这种事情继续下去？正如你所说，把孩子们送进寄宿学校。所以第一批寄宿学校于1879年在宾夕法尼亚州开设。孩子们
arrived, they have their hair forcibly cut, they are baptized as Christians without their parents' consent. All this stuff, which as you say, prefigures what would happen in the 20th century in the US, in Canada, in Australia, and so on. No bear grease. No bear grease in a crow's hair. Yeah. And the tragedy, of course, is that the natives cannot resist because they are now totally dependent on the government dole, on rations, on the agents, the agent's goodwill, because they can't just say, no, I don't fancy this. I'd like to carry on my own life, my old way of life. I'm going off.
到达后，头发被强行剪掉，在未经父母同意的情况下受洗成为基督徒。所有这些事情，正如你所说，预示了20世纪在美国、加拿大、澳大利亚等地将会发生的事情。没有熊油。乌鸦头发里没有熊油。是的。当然，悲剧在于原住民无法反抗，因为他们现在完全依赖政府的救济、口粮和代理人的善意，因为他们不能只是说，不，我不喜欢这样。我想继续我自己的生活，我旧有的生活方式。我要走了。
They're not allowed to do that. Well, they can't because they'd starve, wouldn't they? They would. There's nothing to hunt. There's no bison out there. So they're totally in the power of the agents. So when Sitting Bull arrives at Standing Rock, he is totally in the power of the agents so when sitting bull arrives at standing rock he is totally in the power now of a man called major james mcclaughlin mcclaughlin was a former
他们不被允许这样做。嗯，他们不能，因为他们会饿死，不是吗？他们会的。没有什么可猎捕的。外面没有野牛了。所以他们完全受制于代理人。所以当坐牛到达立岩时，他完全受制于代理人，所以当坐牛到达立岩时，他现在完全受制于一个叫詹姆斯·麦克劳林（James McLaughlin）少校的人，麦克劳林曾是一名
blacksmith his wife was a court of santee and she spoke the kota language fluently so she was the interpreter mcclaughlin is a sort of, he has an enormous moustache. Bigger than Wild Bill Hickox? Probably similar. Wow. Times have changed, Tom. The beard has been consigned to history, a very bad sign. This is the age of the moustache.
铁匠，他的妻子是桑蒂苏族人（Santee），她能流利地说拉科塔语，所以她是翻译。麦克劳林有一种，他留着巨大的胡子。比“狂野比尔”希科克（Wild Bill Hickok）的还大吗？可能差不多。哇。时代变了，汤姆。胡须已经被送进了历史，这是一个非常糟糕的迹象。这是胡子时代。
A more ruthless, pragmatic moustache has entered. Yeah. I mean, he's not an evil man, is he? No. He's a man of high principle. He's a devout Catholic. He thinks that to essentially eradicate what he sees as evil customs is the best course. But reading about how he treats Sitting Bull,
一个更冷酷、更务实的胡子出现了。是的。我的意思是，他不是一个坏人，对吧？不。他是一个有高尚原则的人。他是一个虔诚的天主教徒。他认为从本质上根除他所认为的邪恶习俗是最好的做法。但读到他如何对待坐牛，
there is something of Hudson Lowe, the British jailer on St. Helena, and the way that he deals with Napoleon. Yeah. His autobiography was called My Friend the Indian, but Sitting Bull would not have approved of that title. He is very pragmatic, very ruthless about dividing and ruling among the Indians. So he recruits a man who we encountered earlier in the podcast, one of Sitting Bull's old lieutenants, a man called Gore. I mean, he really is the flashman of the Lakota because he was in trouble for bullying, wasn't he? He was, but as a young man, I think as a slightly older man, he's seen as almost placid. And he explains his behavior at the Battle of Little Bighorn, where he is the guy really
他身上有一种哈德逊·洛（Hudson Lowe）的影子，那个在圣赫勒拿岛看守拿破仑的英国狱卒。是的。他的自传叫《我的印第安朋友》（My Friend the Indian），但坐牛肯定不会赞同这个书名。他在印第安人中搞分而治之非常务实、非常冷酷。所以他招募了一个我们在播客早期遇到过的人，坐牛的老部下之一，一个叫高尔（Gall）的人。我的意思是，他真的是拉科塔人的弗莱什曼（Flashman），因为他曾因欺凌他人而惹上麻烦，不是吗？他是，但作为一个年轻人，我想作为一个稍微年长一点的人，他被视为几乎是温和的。他解释了他在小大角战役中的行为，在那里他是真正
who leads the charge that overwhelms the first stronghold of the 7th Cavalry because he had lost two of his wives and three of his children. That's right. Yeah. I always think of him as somebody who had made the journey from being captain of the rugby 15 or a sort of disputatious boy, the sort of bounder of the class school. He's now the chapel prefect, isn't he? He's the goody two shoes of the Standing Rock agency for Adrian McLaughlin. Well, you say that. He's a very fine figure of a man. And Elizabeth Custer, of all people, meets with him five years after the battle and says, painful as it is for me to look upon the pictured face of an Indian, I never in my life dreamed there could be in all the tribes so fine a specimen of warrior as Gaw.
领导冲锋并压制了第七骑兵团第一个据点的人，因为他失去了两个妻子和三个孩子。没错。是的。我总是认为他是一个从橄榄球队长或某种好争辩的男孩，班级里的那种捣蛋鬼，转变成现在教堂级长的人，不是吗？他是立岩代理处阿德里安·麦克劳林（Adrian McLaughlin）的乖宝宝。嗯，你这么说。他是一个非常魁梧的人。伊丽莎白·卡斯特（Elizabeth Custer）本人在战后五年见到他时说，尽管看着印第安人的照片让我感到痛苦，但我一生中从未梦想过在所有部落中竟然会有像高尔这样出色的战士。
Wow. Is that how she spoke? And compares his bearing to that of a gladiator. Crikey. And he's much photographed. Yeah. compares his bearing to that of a gladiator. And he's much photographed. And the guy who takes the photograph of him says that he's worried that his lens will burst trying to contain the image. Wow.
哇。她是那样说话的吗？并将他的风度比作角斗士。天哪。他被拍了很多照片。是的。并将他的风度比作角斗士。他被拍了很多照片。那个给他拍照的人说，他担心他的镜头会因为试图容纳他的形象而爆裂。哇。
He has a tragic story. I mean, just to kind of preempt it. So as you say, he basically, I mean, he kind of switches sides. He wears European clothing. He becomes a big fan of Mendelssohn, rather improbably. He loves the wedding march and he ends up very fat because, I mean, he does profit from the amount of food on the reservation. He's not being starved and he worries about this. And so he asks, you know, is there anything that could help me get thin again? And he gets given a tonic, but he gets told very strictly, do not have more than, you know, a couple of sips a week because otherwise it'll kill you. And so he has a couple of sips, doesn't seem to have any impact. So he necks the entire bottle and it kills him. Oh my God. What was in the tonic? What kind of diet thing is that? I don't know. I mean, Evan Connell reports it and he says, if true, it sounds like a Chekhov story.
他有一个悲剧性的故事。我的意思是，只是为了预先说明一下。正如你所说，他基本上，我的意思是，他有点倒戈了。他穿欧洲服装。他成了门德尔松（Mendelssohn）的忠实粉丝，这很不寻常。他喜欢《婚礼进行曲》，最后变得非常肥胖，因为，我的意思是，他确实从保留地的食物供应中获利了。他没有挨饿，他对此感到担心。所以他问，你知道，有什么东西能帮我瘦下来吗？他得到了一种补药，但被非常严格地告知，每周不要喝超过几口，否则会要了你的命。所以他喝了几口，似乎没什么效果。于是他一口气喝光了整瓶，结果要了他的命。天哪。补药里有什么？那是什么样的减肥药？我不知道。我的意思是，埃文·康奈尔（Evan Connell）报道了这件事，他说，如果这是真的，听起来就像契诃夫（Chekhov）的故事。
So it may not be true. It's a great story, but that if true is a bit, there's a lot hanging on that, isn't it? Yeah, it's very sad. But anyway, Gould, he's an example of many people who actually, they can't go off having fun on the plane. You talked in, I think, our third or fourth episode about how fun, how exhilarating the plane's life could be, the fighting, the hunting and so on. And for those people who can't do that anymore all you can really do is to join this sort of agency police you join this police force they call the metal breasts because of their badges and that's how you you know that's your new status and your prestige that's what gall and lots of other people do now sitting bull doesn't fit into that world
所以这可能不是真的。这是一个很棒的故事，但那个“如果这是真的”有点，有很多悬念，不是吗？是的，这很悲伤。但总之，高尔，他是许多人的一个例子，实际上，他们不能再在平原上玩耍了。你在我们的第三或第四集里谈到过平原生活是多么有趣、多么令人振奋，战斗、狩猎等等。对于那些不能再那样做的人来说，你唯一能做的就是加入这种代理处警察，你加入这支警察部队，他们因为徽章而被称为“金属胸”（metal breasts），这就是你，你知道，这就是你的新地位和声望，这就是高尔和许多其他人现在所做的。坐牛不适合那个世界，
his appeal his leadership is based on... The old ways. Conservatism, I suppose, on tradition. Yeah. Well, but also his powers of vision. Exactly. You know, hooking up his chest to hooks and things. Yeah, to poles.
他的吸引力、他的领导力是基于……旧的方式。保守主义，我想，基于传统。是的。嗯，但也基于他的愿景力量。没错。你知道，把他的胸部挂在钩子上之类的。是的，挂在杆子上。
Yeah. And there's none of that going on now. No. McLaughlin is very down on that. And actually, when Sitting Bull arrives, McLaughlin effectively says to him, you're not going to be the big man around here. Times have changed. Yeah.
是的。现在没有那种事了。不。麦克劳林对此非常反感。实际上，当坐牛到达时，麦克劳林实际上对他说，你在这里不会成为大人物了。时代变了。是的。
And so he's always doing him down, isn't he? He hates Sitting Bull. He says Sitting Bull was a man of very mediocre ability, rather dull and much inferior of Gaul and others of his lieutenants in intelligence. He's pompous, vain and boastful and considers himself a very important personage. Sitting Bull knows this and he's very miserable about it.
所以他总是贬低他，不是吗？他讨厌坐牛。他说坐牛是一个能力平庸的人，相当迟钝，在智力上远不如高尔和其他部下。他自命不凡、虚荣、爱吹牛，认为自己是一个非常重要的人物。坐牛知道这一点，他对此感到非常痛苦。
You know when we talked about how miserable Crazy Horse was? Sitting Bull is, if anything, even more miserable because he just can't understand why he's being belittled but it's more than that isn't it it's not just that it's that everything that had sustained him has gone totally yeah i mean the entire way of understanding the world has gone. Wherever this happens, wherever Europeans intrude on a society and the impact of modernity and industrialization just destroys that society, people seem left utterly disoriented by it. Which remember, Tom, when we started this series, I said I always thought of the story of Custer as the bridge between the story of first Columbus and then the Aztecs on the one hand, and then Titanic on the other. Yeah.
你知道当我们谈到疯马有多痛苦时吗？坐牛，如果说有什么不同的话，他甚至更痛苦，因为他只是不明白为什么他被轻视，但这不仅仅是那样，不是吗？不仅仅是那样，而是支撑他的一切都消失了。完全是，我的意思是，理解世界的整个方式都消失了。无论这种情况在哪里发生，无论欧洲人闯入一个社会，现代性和工业化的影响摧毁了那个社会，人们似乎都对此感到完全迷失方向。记住，汤姆，当我们开始这个系列时，我说我一直认为卡斯特的故事是连接哥伦比亚（Columbus）和阿兹特克人（Aztecs）的故事，以及泰坦尼克号（Titanic）的故事之间的桥梁。是的。
And if you think back to that Columbus series, when Columbus landed on Hispaniola and then the Spaniards started arriving, the Tainos, the indigenous people, were just totally wiped out through disease, but also through the cruelty of the Spaniards. But also because there were descriptions of them as just sitting down, staring into space, baffled that everything they'd taken for granted, the rhythm of their life, their faith, their sense of what the world was and what the human condition was, had just been utterly destroyed. And I think there must be something similar going on for Sitting Bull here.
如果你回想那个哥伦布系列，当哥伦布登陆伊斯帕尼奥拉岛（Hispaniola），然后西班牙人开始到达时，泰诺人（Tainos），那些原住民，因为疾病，也因为西班牙人的残暴，被彻底消灭了。但也因为有描述说他们只是坐着，盯着虚空，困惑于他们认为理所当然的一切，他们生活的节奏、他们的信仰、他们对世界是什么以及人类状况是什么的感知，都已经被彻底摧毁了。我认为坐牛这里一定也发生了类似的事情。
I think so. Well, I mean, I don't want to go all Foucault. Yeah. But the idea of industrial society as putting a premium on the prison house, on blocking people in within walls, people in Europe find that tough to deal with. Yeah. But for someone like Sitting Bull, who physically has been used to roaming the plains and spiritually consorting with the spirits, being granted visions that open up the heavens. It must just be torture to be stuck in this. Yeah, in the reservation.
我想是的。嗯，我的意思是，我不想变得太福柯（Foucault）。是的。但工业社会将监狱视为一种溢价，将人们限制在墙内，欧洲人觉得这很难应对。是的。但对于像坐牛这样的人来说，他在身体上习惯了在平原上漫游，在精神上与灵魂交流，被赋予了开启天堂的愿景。被困在这里一定是一种折磨。是的，在保留地里。
He's got his little cabin that he's built himself. He says, can I be any lower than I am? Once I was a man, but now I am a pitiful wretch. And actually what I think makes it worse is that he is now treated like a performing bear. So MacLachlan decides he wants to make some money out of Sitting Bull, and he decides he does a deal with our old friends, the Northern Pacific Railroad. They're going to supply passes,
他有他自己盖的小木屋。他说，我还能比现在更低贱吗？曾经我是一个男人，但现在我是一个可怜的苦命人。实际上我认为让他更糟糕的是，他现在被当作一只表演熊来对待。所以麦克劳林决定他想从坐牛身上赚点钱，他决定与我们的老朋友北太平洋铁路公司（Northern Pacific Railroad）做一笔交易。他们将提供通行证，
and they're going to sort out hotels and all that stuff. It's basically Sitting Bull will perform in St. Paul, Minnesota. He will do his act. He will do an act, And they will organize dinners, and there will be bigwigs, and people will come and get his autograph. They put them up at the merchant's hotel. Thousands of people come to see him. Sitting Bull is given tours of the schools, of the fire department, of the post office, all of this sort of stuff. He's made to use a telephone. His nephew, Juan bull, is in the
他们将安排酒店和所有这些东西。基本上坐牛将在明尼苏达州的圣保罗表演。他会表演他的节目。他会表演一个节目，他们会组织晚宴，会有大人物，人们会来找他签名。他们把他安置在商人酒店（Merchant's Hotel）。成千上万的人来看他。坐牛被带去参观学校、消防局、邮局，所有这些东西。他被迫使用电话。他的侄子，胡安·公牛（Juan Bull），在
next room and they have a telephone conversation. Sitting Bull does say, well, that was pretty remarkable. But there's a terrible poignancy to this whole thing that he's been treated as a relic and as a walking gimmick. And so that's in 1884. And then in 1885, I think even worse because two terrible shysters get their claws into him. Oh, yes. So he gets approached by an agent called John Burke, who is known variously as Major John Burke, despite the fact that he's not a major. And Arizona John, despite the fact that he never went to Arizona. And he is acting as the agent for Buffalo Bill Cody. Oh, yeah. Who I think we've already met.
隔壁房间，他们进行了一次电话交谈。坐牛确实说，嗯，那真是太了不起了。但整件事有一种可怕的辛酸，他被当作一个遗迹和一个行走的噱头来对待。所以那是1884年。然后是1885年，我想更糟，因为两个可怕的骗子抓住了他。哦，是的。所以他被一个叫约翰·伯克（John Burke）的代理人接触，他被称为约翰·伯克少校，尽管他不是少校。还有亚利桑那约翰（Arizona John），尽管他从未去过亚利桑那。他担任布法罗·比尔·科迪（Buffalo Bill Cody）的代理人。哦，是的。我想我们已经见过他了。
Bill Cody has got his name Buffalo Bill from the sheer number of buffalo that he's wiped out. So he has acted as a scout for the army. And at one point, actually, in the wake of Little Bighorn, he is serving with the army. And he has this absolute cock and bull story. He's with the Fifth Cavalry. He rides out because there are just a few warriors out there. And he's dressed up exactly like Custer has in all his kind of glad rags. So not in a kind of uniform. And he kills and scalps supposedly this Cheyenne warrior who he calls Yellow Hand, who he says had killed Custer. And this becomes a big story and it kind of spreads across America. And this is what then
比尔·科迪（Bill Cody）因为他消灭的水牛数量之多而得名“布法罗·比尔”。所以他曾担任军队的侦察兵。有一次，实际上，在小大角战役之后，他正在军队服役。他有一个绝对荒诞的故事。他和第五骑兵团在一起。他骑马出去，因为外面只有几个战士。他打扮得和卡斯特在所有盛装中一模一样。所以不是穿制服。他杀死了并剥下了那个他称之为“黄手”（Yellow Hand）的夏延族战士的头皮，他说这个战士杀死了卡斯特。这成了一个大新闻，它传遍了美国。这就是后来
makes Buffalo Bill a kind of big name. And he stages this show the following year in which he, you know, he kind of restages it and he pulls off this scalp and it's supposed to be yellow hand scalp and he waves it in the air and he says, the first scalp for Custer. And so this gives him the idea, well, I can make money from this, from restaging scenes of the West. And he ends up restaging the Battle of Little Bighorn. And for that, he wants Sitting Bull and Sitting Bull agrees. And he goes off on this tour and Sitting Bull comes out and he's riding around the arena and all the crowd are booing him. I mean, they're showing him no respect at all because it's been built up that he's the villain. And I just think it's terrible.
让布法罗·比尔成名的原因。第二年他上演了这个节目，在节目中他，你知道，他重演了那一幕，他剥下了头皮，据说那是黄手的头皮，他在空中挥舞着说，卡斯特的第一张头皮。所以这给了他灵感，嗯，我可以从中赚钱，通过重演西部的场景。他最终重演了小大角战役。为此，他想要坐牛，坐牛同意了。他参加了这次巡演，坐牛出来，他在竞技场里骑马，所有的观众都在嘘他。我的意思是，他们对他一点尊重都没有，因为他被塑造成了反派。我只是觉得这太可怕了。
And actually, Gould, to give him credit, he said, no, I'm not going to do it. I'm not going to be a performing animal. But Sitting Bull does it. And you wonder, why does he do it? To get out? But it's awful. It's really awful. It is awful.
实际上，高尔，值得称赞的是，他说，不，我不干。我不会成为表演动物。但坐牛做了。你可能会问，他为什么要这么做？为了离开？但这太糟糕了。这真的很糟糕。这确实很糟糕。
I was going to say, it sounds a little bit like the Restless History Live shows, Tom. It does. Going around America, being humiliated. But it is terrible. I do think it's terrible. I've thought about this a lot. I was in Monument Valley a year ago, and there are Navajo there, Dine, as they prefer to be called who organize rides you know you get on a horse and you go and you have your photo taken by the rock and they sort of stand beside you and look fearsome there's
我正想说，这听起来有点像《历史的余味》现场秀，汤姆。确实。在全美巡回，被羞辱。但这确实很糟糕。我确实认为这很糟糕。我对此思考了很多。一年前我在纪念碑谷（Monument Valley），那里有纳瓦霍人（Navajo），或者他们更喜欢被称为迪内人（Dine），他们组织骑马活动，你知道，你骑上一匹马，然后去拍照，在岩石旁，他们站在你身边，看起来很凶猛，那里有
John Wayne's points there's all of this stuff and I often have thought to myself since then how different is that really you know we're all partaking yeah they have little shacks selling tomahawks stuff like that that spirit of the reenactment for, frankly, wealthy white audiences, that has never quite gone away. And there is something dreadful about contemplating that scene of Sitting Bull. And also, he's clearly left overwhelmed by what he sees in the West. And he comes back and says, they're all terrible. It's awful.
约翰·韦恩（John Wayne）的拍摄点，所有这些东西。从那以后我经常想，这真的有什么不同吗？你知道，我们都在参与。是的，他们有卖战斧之类东西的小棚子。那种为富有的白人观众进行重演的精神，从来没有真正消失过。凝视坐牛的那一幕确实有些可怕。而且，他显然被他在西部看到的一切所震撼。他回来后说，他们都很可怕。这太糟糕了。
But I think he's gazed into the abyss of what the future will be. And it's a future in which everything that he is, there is no place. And so he does kind of try and knuckle down, doesn't he, to kind of become a farmer. But I mean, it's not sitting bull. And then Dominic, amid his depression, amid the tedium and flatness of his existence, news reaches him of something extraordinary, doesn't he? Something utterly convulsive. Exactly, yeah. Rumors are coming into the reservation of something going on out there beyond the mountains
但我认为他凝视了未来的深渊。这是一个他没有立足之地的未来。所以他确实试图安分守己，不是吗？试图成为一名农民。但我的意思是，那不是坐牛。然后多米尼克，在他抑郁、在他存在的乏味和平庸之中，关于某种非凡事物的消息传到了他耳中，不是吗？某种彻底震撼的东西。没错，是的。关于山外发生的事情的传言传到了保留地，
to the west. Is it a cult? Is it a new religion? But whatever it is, it seems to offer salvation for Sitting Bull and for his people. And this is something called the Ghost Dance. Tom, should we come back after the break to find out what it is? I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
向西。是一个邪教吗？是一种新宗教吗？但无论它是什么，它似乎为坐牛和他的族人提供了救赎。这就是所谓的“鬼舞”。汤姆，我们休息一下回来看看那是什么好吗？我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. So Dominic, just before the break, poor old sitting bull. He's been having a terrible time. He's out to become a farmer. He's been exploited by Buffalo Bill. It's all terrible. But then news of this extraordinary development, the ghost dance. So what is the ghost dance? What is going
我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先购买现场票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。所以多米尼克，就在休息前，可怜的坐牛。他一直过得很糟糕。他想成为一名农民。他被布法罗·比尔剥削。这一切都很糟糕。但随后关于这个非凡发展——鬼舞——的消息传来了。那么什么是鬼舞？发生了什么
on with this? Right. We need to explain where the ghost dance came from. So a little bit of politics. So he hears that there is a cult or a religion or a movement, call it what you will, that offers at last a change in the narrative and salvation for the native people but this hasn't come out of nowhere it doesn't sweep as it does through the reservations out of nowhere and actually the politics is really important so sydney bull probably hears about this this movement in the very end of the 1880s in march 1889 america had a new president ben Benjamin Harrison, a Republican, who was very pro-business, civil war general. He'd been very narrowly elected in November 1888. He'd lost the popular vote, but he'd won the electoral college. He's facing a tricky re-election in 1892. Because they're going to admit a lot of Western states want to come in, and you want to win them for your party. And Harrison and his backers believe that they will be Republican states, that they will be full of Protestant farmers who will vote the Republican ticket. And their priority is to bring those states in as quickly as possible.
事？好的。我们需要解释鬼舞的起源。所以一点政治背景。所以他听说有一个邪教、宗教或运动，随你怎么称呼，它终于为原住民提供了叙事的改变和救赎，但这并不是凭空出现的，它并不是像它席卷保留地那样凭空出现的，实际上政治非常重要。所以坐牛可能在19世纪80年代末听说了这个运动。1889年3月，美国有了一位新总统本杰明·哈里森（Benjamin Harrison），一位共和党人，他非常支持商业，是内战时期的将军。他在1888年11月以微弱优势当选。他输掉了普选，但赢得了选举人团。他面临着1892年棘手的连任选举。因为他们要接纳很多想要加入的西部州，而你想为你的政党赢得这些州。哈里森和他的支持者相信这些州将是共和党州，它们将充满会投票给共和党的新教农民。他们的首要任务是尽快让这些州加入。
It will give them the balance of power in Congress, and it will change the makeup of the Electoral College. And what they want to do is they think, they look at the Dakota Territory, where Sitting Bull's agency is, Standing Rock Agency, and all the Lakotas, and they say, we want to bring that in as two states, not one. We'll have a North Dakota and a South Dakota. But the problem is, much of South Dakota is the Great Sioux Reservation, so it's not really viable as a state. So ideally, they want to break up the reservation into six smaller reservations and encourage lots of white settlement. Now, people have been talking about this for quite a while. There was something called the Dawes Act a few years earlier. But Harrison really wants to accelerate it.
这会给他们在国会中带来权力平衡，并改变选举人团的构成。他们想做的是，他们看着达科他领地（Dakota Territory），也就是坐牛的代理处所在地，立岩代理处，以及所有的拉科塔人，他们说，我们想把这里作为两个州而不是一个州加入。我们将有一个北达科他州和一个南达科他州。但问题是，南达科他州的大部分是大苏族保留地，所以作为州来说并不太可行。所以理想情况下，他们想把保留地拆分成六个较小的保留地，并鼓励大量的白人定居。现在，人们已经谈论这件事很久了。几年前有一个叫道斯法案（Dawes Act）的东西。但哈里森真的想加速它。
And in 1889, Congress approves that they're going to break up the Great Sioux Reservation, and they send General Crook. Remember General Crook from the previous episodes? Yeah. They sent him. They said, the Indians know him. He's an old hand. He'll know how to handle them.
1889年，国会批准拆分大苏族保留地，他们派出了克鲁克将军。还记得前几集里的克鲁克将军吗？是的。他们派了他。他们说，印第安人认识他。他是个老手。他会知道如何处理他们。
And actually they're right. Crook goes to meet the chiefs and he says, look, you don't like it. I understand that. But you're in the position of somebody whose stuff is belongings. They're in a dry stream and there's a flood coming. And you can either stand there and moan and groan that the flood is coming or you can move your belongings. And that, I'm afraid, is what you're going to have to do. It is what it is, babes.
实际上他们是对的。克鲁克去见酋长们，他说，看，你们不喜欢这样。我理解。但你们现在的处境就像一个东西被……的人。他们在干涸的河床上，洪水要来了。你们要么站在那里抱怨洪水要来了，要么搬走你们的财物。恐怕这就是你们必须做的。事实就是这样，宝贝。
Correct. And that's what they do. That's a very unexpected remark there, Tom, but I enjoyed it. You know, sums it up really. I got the reference. Now, 99.9% of the listeners won't if they haven't read the rest of this history book, which I heartily recommend. So this decision, which is basically done so that the Republicans can get these two states in,
没错。他们就是这么做的。汤姆，那是一个非常出人意料的评论，但我很喜欢。你知道，总结得很好。我听懂了这个梗。现在，99.9%的听众如果没读过《历史的余味》这本书就不会懂，我强烈推荐这本书。所以这个决定，基本上是为了让共和党人获得这两个州，
is a total and utter unmitigated disaster for the Lakota. They lose half of their land overnight. What little hunting they had left is completely obliterated. They are now totally the prisoners of the agents on the reservations. And what is more, this coincides with Congress deciding that it'd actually like to make some economies. So they slashed their rations, even though Crook promised that they wouldn't. So in the winter of 1889, 1890, they starve, terrible hunger, disease, measles, whooping cough, influenza. They sweep through the reservations. Some people may remember that when we did the Battle of the Little Bighorn, there was
对拉科塔人来说是一场彻底的、完全的、无可挽回的灾难。他们一夜之间失去了半数土地。他们仅存的一点狩猎活动被彻底抹杀。他们现在完全成了保留地代理人的囚犯。更重要的是，这恰逢国会决定实际上想要节省开支。所以他们削减了口粮，尽管克鲁克承诺他们不会。所以在1889年到1890年的冬天，他们挨饿，极度的饥饿，疾病，麻疹，百日咳，流感。它们席卷了保留地。有些人可能还记得，当我们讲小大角战役时，有一个
a character called Black Elk. Remember Black Elk, Tom? Yes, the little boy. He was a teenager, yeah, who scal Remember Black Elk, Tom? Yes. The little boy. He was a teenager. Yeah. Who scalped a trooper. Dreadful scene. Hunted him like a rabbit in a bush. That's right. He later gave, there's a book called Black Elk Speaks, one of the great kind of classics of writing about Native Americans. Black Elk says of that winter, the people seemed heavy to me, heavy and dark. So heavy it seemed they couldn't be lifted. So dark
角色叫黑麋鹿（Black Elk）。还记得黑麋鹿吗，汤姆？是的，那个小男孩。他是个少年，是的，他剥了……还记得黑麋鹿吗，汤姆？是的。那个小男孩。他是个少年。是的。他剥了一名士兵的头皮。可怕的场景。像灌木丛里的兔子一样猎杀他。没错。他后来给出了，有一本书叫《黑麋鹿如是说》（Black Elk Speaks），是关于美洲原住民写作的伟大经典之一。黑麋鹿谈到那个冬天时说，人们在我看来很沉重，沉重而黑暗。沉重得似乎无法被举起。如此黑暗，
they couldn't be made to see anymore. Hunger was us now there were many lies but we could not eat them i mean that is that's a terrible sentence isn't it yeah it is and it's in that context that the lakota hear a rumor that far away beyond the rocky mountains a messiah has come who will liberate them they send a little party and the two most prominent people a guy called kicking bear who is a cousin of crazy horse and a medicine man from the brulee called short bull off these guys go obviously it's a long way away so they've gone for ages and they come back in march 1890 and they say, unbelievable news. The Messiah is there. The son of the Holy Spirit, of the great spirits rather. Well, I mean, that's a kind of telling step, isn't it? Because I mean,
以至于他们再也看不见了。饥饿现在就是我们，有很多谎言，但我们无法吃掉它们。我的意思是，那是一个可怕的句子，不是吗？是的，确实如此。正是在这种背景下，拉科塔人听到一个传言，远在落基山脉之外，一位弥赛亚已经到来，他将解放他们。他们派出了一个小分队，两个最突出的人，一个叫踢熊（Kicking Bear）的人，他是疯马的表亲，还有一个来自布鲁尔（Brulee）的巫医叫短牛（Short Bull），这些人出发了，显然路途遥远，所以他们去了很久，在1890年3月回来，他们说，难以置信的消息。弥赛亚在那里。圣灵的儿子，或者说是伟大灵魂的儿子。嗯，我的意思是，这是一个很有说明意义的步骤，不是吗？因为我的意思是，
this is what's so fascinating is that it's a conflation of traditional beliefs with Christianity. Yeah. And he has come to basically liberate us. So wonderful news, liberation is at hand. And it's going to happen actually next spring, spring of 1891. Brilliant. And this bloke, this Messiah, his name was Wawoka, or his white friends knew him as Jack Wilson, which is a little bit less inspirational his 30s and he was a medicine man with the Paiute, but he was very westernized as it were, sort of Christianized, I suppose. He dressed like the white man's clothing. He worked for a rancher. He spoke English and he had clearly learned about Christianity from this rancher out there in Nevada. And the story goes that it was during a solar eclipse in 1889 that he had fallen very badly ill and he had had a vision and he had ascended into heaven and God had given him the good news and said, Jesus is on his way, fantastic scenes,
这正是令人着迷的地方，它是传统信仰与基督教的融合。是的。他基本上是来解放我们的。所以好消息，解放即将来临。而且实际上就在明年春天，1891年春天。太棒了。这个家伙，这个弥赛亚，他的名字叫沃沃卡（Wovoka），或者他的白人朋友称他为杰克·威尔逊（Jack Wilson），这听起来没那么有灵感，他30多岁，是派尤特人（Paiute）的巫医，但他非常西化，或者说基督教化，我想。他穿着白人的衣服。他为牧场主工作。他会说英语，显然是从内华达州的那位牧场主那里学到了基督教。故事是这样的，在1889年日食期间，他病得很重，他看到了幻象，他升入了天堂，上帝给了他好消息，说，耶稣正在路上，美妙的场景，
and he's actually coming to help the native people. But it's unclear, isn't it, whether he is actually Jesus because doesn't native people but it's unclear isn't it whether he is actually jesus because doesn't he have stigmata yes he does the kind of the wounds of the nails in his hands and feet he does indeed and the trouble is the accounts we have of him are very garbled and slightly contradictory and what is clear as well is that the lakota emissaries who returned so kicking bear and short bull distorted his message in some way yeah so it's very unclear but what is clear is that he says good times are ahead for the plains indians but what you absolutely must do he said is you must be peaceful you must remain at peace you mustn't take up arms you must show love
他确实是来帮助原住民的。但这一点并不明确，不是吗？他真的是耶稣吗？因为他手上和脚上不是有圣痕吗？是的，他确实有，就是钉痕。确实如此，问题在于我们关于他的记载非常混乱且略有矛盾。同样清楚的是，返回的拉科塔族特使，也就是“踢熊”和“短牛”，在某种程度上歪曲了他的信息。是的，所以这很不清楚，但明确的是，他说平原印第安人的好日子就要来了，但他还说，你们绝对必须做的是，你们必须和平，你们必须保持和平，你们绝不能拿起武器，你们必须展现爱。
and above all you must dance the dance is really. So the dance will be a big thing where you dance around a pole, a little bit like a sun dance. The more you dance, as you dance, you break down the barriers between this world and the next. So you'll be able to see and feel, I guess, your dead family and friends, hence the name the ghost dance. You dress in these white robes or shirts, which are decorated with moons and stars and things.
最重要的是，你们必须跳舞，舞蹈真的很重要。所以舞蹈将是一件大事，你们会绕着一根柱子跳舞，有点像太阳舞。你们跳得越多，在跳舞的过程中，你们就打破了这个世界和下一个世界之间的隔阂。所以我想，你们将能够看到并感受到你们死去的家人和朋友，这就是“鬼舞”这个名字的由来。你们穿着这些装饰着月亮、星星之类的白色长袍或衬衫。
And they're kind of proof against bullets, aren't they? They're proof against bullets. Although it's not clear whether that's a detail that was added later, whether he said they were proof against bullets. And it's communal. So it's a different kind of dance from the sun dance. Because in the sun dance... Yeah, it's competitive, isn't it?
而且它们能防弹，不是吗？它们能防弹。虽然不清楚这是否是后来添加的细节，也不清楚他是否真的说过它们能防弹。而且这是集体性的。所以这与太阳舞不同。因为在太阳舞中……是的，那是竞争性的，不是吗？
Obviously, the sun dance is kind of... There's loads of people there. But in the Sundance, you personally commune with the spirits. And it's very much a private experience for you. But also, if you fail at it, then you fail as an individual. Yeah, you do. Whereas in the Ghost Dance, you're all holding hands, which the Sioux didn't used to do when they danced.
显然，太阳舞有点……那里有很多人。但在太阳舞中，你是个人与灵魂交流。这对你来说是非常私人的体验。而且，如果你失败了，那么作为个人你就失败了。是的，确实如此。而在鬼舞中，你们都手拉手，这是苏族人以前跳舞时不会做的。
So it's very much everybody together. And as soon as you've had a vision, you must share it with your friends and swap the good news and all this kind of stuff. So very kind of Quaker-ish. Yeah. Assembly, the spirit coming on you, talking, having visions, Pentecost list, speaking in tongues. I think what is obvious and what lots of people have said is
所以这非常强调大家在一起。一旦你有了异象，你必须与朋友分享，交换好消息等等。所以这有点像贵格会。是的。聚会、灵魂降临、说话、产生异象、五旬节派、说方言。我认为显而易见且许多人已经说过的是
this is quite obviously a fusion of Christianity and elements of native, I know you say religion is the wrong word, native spirituality. I mean, let's say, because it is becoming a religion. Yeah, being codified. Because the native peoples of America are being Americanized. So it's a fusion of those things, but also it's happening out West. And there was a lot of Mormonism in there almost certainly as well. So all of those things, but also it's happening out West. And there was a lot of Mormonism in there, almost certainly as well. So all of these things are mixed up.
这显然是基督教与原住民元素——我知道你说宗教这个词不对——原住民灵性的融合。我的意思是，我们就这么说吧，因为它正在成为一种宗教。是的，正在被编纂。因为美国的原住民正在被美国化。所以这是这些事物的融合，而且它发生在西部。而且几乎可以肯定，其中也有很多摩门教的成分。所以所有这些事物都混杂在一起。
No one doubts that this guy, by the way, Wovoka, he's not a con man. He's not a demagogue or anything like that. There's no reason to doubt his sincerity. Well, it's often said that what happens in the kind of colonial peripheries in the long run will blow back and hit the metropoles of the West. And it kind of reminds me of spiritualism in the wake of the First World War. Oh, yeah. The desperate yearning of people to be in touch with those that they've loved.
顺便说一句，没有人怀疑这个叫沃沃卡的家伙，他不是骗子。他不是煽动者之类的。没有理由怀疑他的诚意。嗯，人们常说，从长远来看，殖民地边缘发生的事情会反噬并冲击西方的中心。这让我想起了第一次世界大战后的唯灵论。哦，是的。人们渴望与他们所爱的人保持联系的绝望渴望。
And these visions in eclipses, I mean, this is what happens, the visions of Fatima, these extraordinary visions, supposedly of the Virgin Mary. Something very similar, this sense of in the wake of an unbelievable catastrophe, the yearning for communion with what you have lost. And ultimately this is what it's like. And it seems like a kind of foreshadowing of what will happen in Europe a few decades later. Yeah. I think that belief in, I want to commune with the dead. I guess because the dead, it's not just because the dead in themselves, it's because of
还有这些日食中的异象，我的意思是，这就是发生的事情，法蒂玛的异象，这些非凡的异象，据说是圣母玛利亚的。非常相似，这种在难以置信的灾难之后，渴望与你失去的东西交流的感觉。归根结底，这就是它的样子。这似乎是几十年后欧洲将要发生的事情的一种预兆。是的。我认为那种信念，我想与死者交流。我想是因为死者，不仅仅是因为死者本身，而是因为
what they represent, which is that old world. Right. Because also, I mean, in a way, the most moving thing of all is that they say the buffalo will come back. Yeah. I mean, it's so painful. Anyway, this starts to spread and, you know, people are excited about it, but actually it probably wouldn't really have caught on if it hadn't been for the fact that in the summer of 1890 as if they haven't suffered enough there is a terrible drought there are days and days of like baking hot skies and burning winds and all the crops on the reservations of south dakota wither and die the hay turns brown as peter cousins puts it in his book on the indian South Dakota wither and die. The hay turns brown. As Peter Cousins puts it in his book on the Indian Wars,
他们所代表的东西，那就是旧世界。对。因为，从某种意义上说，最感人的是他们说野牛会回来。是的。我的意思是，这太痛苦了。无论如何，这开始传播，你知道，人们对此感到兴奋，但实际上，如果不是因为1890年的夏天，他们可能真的不会流行起来，好像他们受的苦还不够多，那年发生了可怕的干旱，有好多天像烘烤般炎热的天空和灼热的风，南达科他州保留地的所有庄稼都枯萎死亡，干草变成了褐色，正如彼得·库辛斯在他的印第安战争一书中所写的那样，
the baked soil became fertile ground for the new faith and hunger nourished its growth. And I mean, one of the agents, an agent called Valentine McGillicuddy, he said, the dance and its ceremonies was like the voice of a feast to a starving man. Those people had been well fed. The ghost dance would never have been heard of actually if congress had not cut their rations by so much the ghost dance would probably
干裂的土壤成了新信仰的肥沃土壤，饥饿滋养了它的生长。我的意思是，其中一位代理人，一个叫瓦伦丁·麦吉利卡迪的代理人说，舞蹈及其仪式就像给饥饿的人的一场盛宴。如果那些人吃饱了，鬼舞实际上永远不会被听说过，如果国会没有削减他们那么多的口粮，鬼舞可能
never have taken root in the way that it did so what happened is that by that summer a version of the ghost dance craze has come to the reservations but it's been twisted it's much more militant so definitely now we have the stuff about the white shirts will protect you from bullets. So conflict is kind of expected and it's much more aggressively anti-white settler, as in they will be eliminated. That they will go. They will go. And as the weeks pass, I mean, people are very hungry, of course. The baking summer turns very quickly to freezing autumn and winter, and the dances continue and they become ever more fervent. People are
永远不会以那种方式扎根。所以发生的事情是，到了那个夏天，鬼舞狂热的一个版本已经传到了保留地，但它被扭曲了，变得更加激进。所以现在我们肯定有了关于白衬衫能保护你不受子弹伤害的内容。所以冲突是预料之中的，而且它对白人定居者更加具有攻击性，意思是他们将被消灭。他们会离开。他们会离开。随着几周过去，我的意思是，人们当然非常饥饿。炎热的夏天很快变成了寒冷的秋天和冬天，舞蹈继续进行，变得越来越狂热。人们
collapsing and sort of, as you said, sort of speaking in tongues, screaming, foaming at the mouth. There is this sort of incredible, incredible excitement. Now, all of this might have been very unsettling and incendiary to kind of their new white neighbours. Of course, they do have white neighbours now, farmers in the Dakotas, who are bound to be a little bit perturbed by this. Although, to be honest, settlers in the West, I mean, they're used to weird expressions of religious faith. That's true. People speaking in tongues and babbling, aren't they? So it's not totally weird to them, I guess. But what actually really turbocharges it is how the agent at one particular place,
倒下，正如你所说，有点像说方言，尖叫，口吐白沫。有一种令人难以置信的兴奋。现在，所有这些对他们的新白人邻居来说可能非常令人不安和具有煽动性。当然，他们现在确实有白人邻居，达科他州的农民，他们注定会对此感到有点不安。虽然说实话，西部的定居者，我的意思是，他们习惯了奇怪的宗教信仰表达。那是真的。人们说方言和胡言乱语，不是吗？所以我想这对他们来说并不完全奇怪。但真正让它加速的是，在某个特定地方的代理人，
Pine Ridge, handles it. And here again, we go back to the politics. Because we said before, the Republican Party is desperate to attract Western voters. Elections at this period are really tightly contested. And Benjamin Harrison only beat in Grover Cleveland in the electoral college, not in the popular vote. Everything matters. And politics in this era is all about patronage. And so they want to put Republicans into political appointments. And the job of being an Indian agent was a really valuable one. It's kind of plum. You control thousands of dollars of contracts to feed the people on the reservation
派恩里奇，是如何处理它的。在这里，我们又回到了政治。因为我们之前说过，共和党急于吸引西部选民。这一时期的选举竞争非常激烈。本杰明·哈里森在选举人团中击败了格罗弗·克利夫兰，而不是在普选中。一切都很重要。这个时代的政治完全是关于恩庇的。所以他们想把共和党人安插到政治职位上。而担任印第安代理人的工作是一个非常有价值的职位。这算是个肥差。你控制着数千美元的合同来喂养保留地上的人，
and to build mills and schools and things. And the South Dakota Republican Party give the job at Pine Ridge that year, 1890, to somebody who could not be more useless. He's called Daniel F. Royer. I mean, he's 36, but in that time, he had been a doctor, a newspaperman, a banker, a territorial delegate, a drugstore guy, and says one person who writes about him, and quite possibly a narcotics addict.
并建造磨坊和学校之类的东西。南达科他州共和党在那一年，即1890年，把派恩里奇的工作给了某个人，他简直不能再没用了。他叫丹尼尔·F·罗耶。我的意思是，他36岁，但在那之前，他当过医生、报社记者、银行家、地区代表、药店老板，正如一个写过他的人所说，很可能还是个毒品成瘾者。
So he's just a serial failure. But he's got connections. They give him the job. He pitches up on the reservation, and he totally loses it. He panics completely. Because he sees them dancing, and he goes out, and he says, oh, you should stop this business. And they all laugh at him, the Lakota. And then he panics and says, you've got to send troops. These people are laughing at me. This is dreadful. And then he starts telling the press, these people are dancing. They're planning an uprising. Blood will flow.
所以他只是一个连续失败者。但他有关系。他们给了他这份工作。他来到保留地，完全失去了理智。他彻底恐慌了。因为他看到他们在跳舞，他走出去说，哦，你们应该停止这种勾当。拉科塔人都在嘲笑他。然后他恐慌了，说，你们必须派军队。这些人正在嘲笑我。这太可怕了。然后他开始告诉媒体，这些人正在跳舞。他们正在策划起义。鲜血将会流淌。
We need to strike first, All of this kind of stuff. And Dominic, the background for this is what Buffalo Bill represents, which is the dramatisation of the Indian wars as entertainment. So it's as vivid in people's minds as ever. And the association of Indians with tomahawks and scalpings and mutilations is completely uppermost in people's mind and not the sufferings that they're going through. No. Remember, we're in 1889, 1890. So if you're 20 or so, or 25, 30 now, you've grown up with the kind of dime novel stories of the battles on the plains in the 1860s, the massacres, all of that stuff. So that is in
我们需要先发制人，所有这些东西。多米尼克，这一切的背景是布法罗·比尔所代表的东西，即把印第安战争戏剧化为娱乐。所以它在人们心中和以往一样生动。印第安人与战斧、剥头皮和残肢断臂的联系完全占据了人们的思想，而不是他们正在经历的苦难。不。记住，我们是在1889年、1890年。所以如果你现在20岁左右，或者25、30岁，你是伴随着1860年代平原战斗、大屠杀之类的廉价小说故事长大的。所以这在
people's imaginations. Absolutely. And it's playing on that. Now, actually, in Washington, when people hear these reports about the ghost dance, as so often, the senior military officers say, oh, this is absolute balderdash. They're just having a dance. Let them crack on with it. It's just a craze. It will pass. I mean, they're totally right on that, by the way. But President Harrison wants to look strong and decisive. South Dakota is actually about to send a new senator to the US Senate. He wants that to be a Republican because that will hold the balance of power in Congress. He wants to impress the voters of South Dakota and the state legislature. And he knows that actually if the army were sent in, the army bring money with them because
人们的想象中。绝对是。而且它在利用这一点。现在，实际上，在华盛顿，当人们听到这些关于鬼舞的报告时，正如经常发生的那样，高级军事官员说，哦，这完全是胡说八道。他们只是在跳舞。让他们继续吧。这只是一种狂热。它会过去的。我的意思是，顺便说一句，他们完全正确。但哈里森总统想表现得强大和果断。南达科他州实际上即将向美国参议院派遣一名新参议员。他希望那是一名共和党人，因为这将掌握国会的权力平衡。他想给南达科他州的选民和州议会留下深刻印象。而且他知道，实际上如果军队被派进去，军队会带来钱，因为
there's all the contracts to supply them and there's all that. And in an area that is suffering from drought and depression, brilliant. It's a win-win situation for him. He looks strong and the voters like him. Yeah. He reinflicts the economy. Exactly. So he sends Nelson A. Miles, the guy who had basically beaten the natives
有所有的供应合同，还有所有这些。在一个遭受干旱和萧条的地区，太棒了。对他来说这是一个双赢的局面。他看起来很强大，选民也喜欢他。是的。他重振了经济。正是如此。所以他派出了纳尔逊·A·迈尔斯，那个基本上击败了原住民的人
in the aftermath of Little Bighorn. So General Miles, he's quite sympathetic to the Indians. He says they've been very badly treated. I don't think this ghost dance is a big deal. But another sort of bizarre political element to this, this is an age when all the talk in Washington is about the Navy. The future will belong to world's great navies. That's what power is. So Congress is giving loads of funds to the Navy and not to the army. And Miles thinks, hold on, if we'd make a bit of a
在小大角战役之后。所以迈尔斯将军，他对印第安人相当同情。他说他们受到了非常糟糕的对待。我不认为这个鬼舞是什么大不了的事。但这是另一个奇怪的政治因素，这是一个华盛顿所有谈话都关于海军的时代。未来将属于世界伟大的海军。这就是权力。所以国会正在给海军提供大量资金，而不是给陆军。迈尔斯想，等等，如果我们能在南达科他州做一点
show of things up there in South Dakota, people will see that the army is very important after all. We'll get lots of money and we'll get what i've always wanted what the army have always wanted we want to run indian policy ourselves we don't want the civilians making a mess of it so miles says fine i'll mobilize the army he mobilizes a quarter of the entire fighting strength of the u.s army 5 000 men it's not a very big army the american army at this point almost Almost as small as the British army. Yeah, exactly. They're rushed in by railroad. The largest army mobilization since the Civil War.
展示，人们最终会看到陆军是非常重要的。我们会得到很多钱，我们会得到我一直想要的，陆军一直想要的，我们想自己管理印第安政策，我们不想让平民把事情搞砸。所以迈尔斯说，好吧，我会动员军队。他动员了美国陆军全部战斗力的四分之一，5000人。这不是一支很大的军队，美国陆军在这一点上几乎和英国陆军一样小。是的，完全正确。他们被铁路迅速运送过去。这是自内战以来最大规模的军队动员。
Just for a load of blokes in white shirts dancing around a pole. Having a dance. And actually, Miles handles it really well. He cordons off the reservations. His men say to the Lakota leaders, guys, pipe down. Chill out. Calm down. Yeah, exactly. his men say to the lakota leaders guys you know pipe down chill out calm down yeah exactly and those people who so some of them have started sort of roaming around and leaving the reservations they are persuaded to go back everything's calmed down but the terrible irony by sending the troops
仅仅是为了对付一群穿着白衬衫绕着柱子跳舞的家伙。跳个舞。实际上，迈尔斯处理得非常好。他封锁了保留地。他的人对拉科塔领袖说，伙计们，安静点。冷静点。放松点。是的，完全正确。那些开始四处游荡并离开保留地的人，他们被说服回去了。一切都平静下来了，但可怕的讽刺是，通过派遣军队，
the administration and miles have actually ignited a press feeding frenzy because loads of reporters have piled in South Dakota. There's no story because there's no fighting. So they invent a story and they say, you know, any moment now the massacres will begin. You know, it goes back to what you were saying, Tom, about the Buffalo Bill show. They're playing with the stories that people are familiar with. The Tomahawks are being sharpened as we speak, all this kind of thing. The tom-toms of war are sounding.
政府和迈尔斯实际上引发了一场媒体狂热，因为大量记者涌入了南达科他州。没有故事，因为没有战斗。所以他们编造了一个故事，他们说，你知道，大屠杀随时可能开始。你知道，这回到了你刚才说的，汤姆，关于布法罗·比尔的表演。他们正在利用人们熟悉的故事。战斧正在磨快，所有这些东西。战争的战鼓正在敲响。
I mean, the storm clouds of war, Tom, have never been darker than at this point. And of course, the man they blame, the man they point the finger at, they need a supervillain and they pick the one Indian that everybody has heard of who has appeared in shows is Sitting Bull. And who is conveniently on location. He's on location. They call him the high priest of the Indian messiah craze. And so General Miles reads all this stuff in the newspapers and he says very wearily, kind of, fine, you know, we'll round up Sitting Bull.
我的意思是，战争的乌云，汤姆，从来没有像现在这样黑暗。当然，他们指责的人，他们指责的人，他们需要一个超级恶棍，他们挑选了每个人都听说过的、出现在表演中的那个印第安人，就是坐牛。而且他正好在现场。他在现场。他们称他为印第安弥赛亚狂热的大祭司。所以迈尔斯将军在报纸上读到了所有这些东西，他非常疲惫地说，好吧，你知道，我们会围捕坐牛。
We'll put him in custody or whatever. Agent McLaughlin, who hates Sitting Bull, he's all over it. He says, brilliant, I'll handle this. There is talk, isn't there, of bringing in Buffalo Bill? Well, Buffalo Bill wants to do it. He says, I know Sitting Bull. I've worked with Sitting Bull. I'll persuade Sitting Bull. General Miles says, yeah, good plan. Gets Buffalo Bill to do it. And McLaughlin, the agent, says, no, I want to handle this myself. I'm going to do it. With disastrous consequences. Tragic consequences. The final act in this extraordinary story that we've been saying, and we will finish the episode there. Originally, this was meant to be four episodes,
我们会把他关押起来或者什么的。讨厌坐牛的麦克劳克林代理人，他对此非常热衷。他说，太棒了，我来处理这件事。有传言说，不是吗，要请布法罗·比尔来？嗯，布法罗·比尔想做。他说，我认识坐牛。我和坐牛一起工作过。我会说服坐牛。迈尔斯将军说，是的，好计划。让布法罗·比尔去做。而代理人麦克劳克林说，不，我想自己处理这件事。我要去做。结果是灾难性的。悲剧性的后果。我们一直在说的这个非凡故事的最后一幕，我们将在那里结束这一集。最初，这应该是四集，
then eight, then 10. It is now going to be 11. I'll take some of the blame, but not all of it. I'm not taking all of the blame for this. Dominic, you are like General Custer, roaming all over the place, refusing to stay where you should, or indeed like Crazy Horse. You're not going to be penned in, are you? No, no. You just want to get out there, be free.
然后是八集，然后是10集。现在它将是11集。我会承担一些责任，但不是全部。我不会承担所有的责任。多米尼克，你就像卡斯特将军，到处游荡，拒绝待在你应该待的地方，或者确实像疯马。你不会被关起来，是吗？不，不。你只是想出去，获得自由。
Is there anybody involved with this podcast who rings the other presenter up 10 minutes before they're due to record and says,'ve got loads of extra notes let's do the extra notes i know well i also want to break free we're both very much to blame for this so anyway this is now going to absolutely be our longer series we're going to have one more episode and in that we are going to look at the fate of sitting bull and what happens to the Ghost Dancers. And we will finally get to Wounded Knee. If you would like to hear that immediately, therestishistory.com. You can sign up there. If not, we'll be back with it very soon. Thank you for sticking with us, if you have. Well, if you haven't, you're not listening.
有没有参与这个播客的人在录制前10分钟给另一位主持人打电话说，“我有很多额外的笔记，我们做额外的笔记吧”，我知道，好吧，我也想获得自由，我们俩都对此负有很大责任。所以无论如何，这现在绝对会成为我们更长的系列。我们将再有一集，在那一集中，我们将看看坐牛的命运以及鬼舞者发生了什么。我们最终会到达伤膝河。如果你想立即听到，therestishistory.com。你可以在那里注册。如果没有，我们很快就会回来。感谢你们的坚持，如果你们有的话。好吧，如果你们没有，你们就不会在听了。
And if you haven't, I don't care because you've gone. Exactly. It's on that bombshell of indifference. Goodbye. Exactly. On that bombshell of indifference. Goodbye. Goodbye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly
而且如果你们没有，我不在乎，因为你们已经走了。正是如此。就在那种冷漠的重磅炸弹上。再见。正是如此。就在那种冷漠的重磅炸弹上。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你们每周的
fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。